thank you skillshare for sponsoring this
video do you know the hidden meaning
behind hanami being the embodiment of
nature
so the unquestionable highlight of the
first season of due to kaisen my
favorite anime of the year so far
is the battle between the special great
curse hanami
and several of the strongest sorcerer
students during the invasion of tokyo
jude sohai
not only do we get some of the most
stunning fighting animation i've seen in
a while but the arc is filled with
important moments of character
development and growth across the board
but i think that in the excitement of
the spectacular display of collaboration
effort and determination by tadorian ko
the secret hero of the scene's success
got
ignored by most fans which is a shame
because when you take a moment to think
about it hanami
is so much more than just another curse
i'm gonna go so far and say that you
probably didn't even realize all the
symbolism united in her character the
message akutami is sending by having the
students
literally fight mother nature and the
fact that hanami is
more good guy than bad guy oh yeah and
let's be honest her character design and
powers are just
the most pleasant mix of creepy elegant
and badass
this is the character analysis of hanami
the spirit
of nature
number one to get it out of the way i'm
gonna call hanami
a her for reasons you'll understand in a
bit i don't even get why this debate is
a thing in the first place but
people seem to be really obsessed with
whether this armored beast made of
cursed energy
is a guy or a girl it's not like cursed
spirits have offspring in general
anyways is it
common
well that's awkward moving on the first
time i saw hanami i
immediately thought that this was one of
the most badass character designs
i've seen in a while because i mean
the muscular white body the hidden arm
the helmet like head with the teeth
exposed
and finally the branches for ice i was
absolutely blown away by the design here
and on top of all that it was speaking
in this
eerie tongue with a female voice by the
way that gave it that vibe of something
ancient and mystical even without
knowing
anything about this curse it radiated
danger by the way did you know that when
you reverse hanami's voice you can
actually understand what she's saying
what now the next time hanami showed up
i was completely startled to see her
approaching gojol the strongest being
alive without being noticed
used by far the most beautiful curse
technique in the story that drains away
one's will to fight
divert gojo's attention by attacking
itadori and actually being able to
escape with jogo who otherwise would
have fallen into the sorceress hands
i love the writing in the scene because
we got so much power scaling and setup
here as soon as joe was introduced
despite all his power he loses against
gojo
who also finally fully demonstrates his
strength
however that same loss is also used as
an opportunity to show how
intelligent hanami's way of thinking and
fighting is and even more than that it
shows us that these curses
actually care for each other hanami
doesn't have to save jogo
but she does so anyways
keep the scene in mind because it will
be important to what hanami is all about
okay so at this point hanami was
probably the most intriguing curse for
me that i wanted to see more of
as i explained in his video mato's
perfectly written evil just
creeps you out every single time you see
him which
made me really tense and anxious every
time we see him fight someone
his cruelty and childish attire make him
a wonderful horror element
but his scenes are meant to upset not to
please
hanami on the other hand i knew i wanted
to see an action her character promised
an immensely enjoyable and
engaging fight based on power and
ability
and oh boy did the story deliver but
first
at break okay real quick i want to talk
about learning new stuff
how to make better decisions how to make
better videos how to make better
coffee i always want to improve my own
skill set get better at doing what i do
and do things i haven't done before and
one of my
favorite places to do that is skillshare
the sponsor of today's video thank you
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an amazing online learning
community that offers
thousands of classes for all skill
levels in tons of creative and practical
disciplines like filmmaking
cooking and art i absolutely love this
course by my fellow german colleagues
over at kutzgazakt on
how they create their wonderful
animations the first 1000 of you foxes
to click the link in the description
we'll get a one month free trial of
skillshare so you can start exploring
your creativity today
okay let's get back to the best anime
fight in 2021
the battle during the exchange event
both animation
and plot wise was some of the best i've
seen in anime to this point
finally i saw hanami fully express her
personality and powers
that did not disappoint using a variety
of nature-based attacks ranging from
cursed buds that suck out cursed energy
over floating wooden balls that allow
her to attack and levitate
to the manifestation of enormous roots
that she can summon and erase from
reality
the special great curse was able to take
on six
of the school's most elite youtube
students rendering the majority of them
unable to fight after encountering her
and the plan here was pretty damn good i
think
use hanami's unique abilities to hide
her presence and sneak into the arena
and cause chaos
distracting everyone enough to allow
mahito to steal sukuna's fingers
and the cursed wombs given her wide
range attacks and sturdiness hanami was
the perfect candidate to buy time and
once again it took gojo for her to
retreat
badly wounded from his attack that of
course i'm gonna show here because
it's my favorite scene from the first
season of the anime
you can be sure that gojo was pissed
that this curse managed to escape him
twice already
what i found absolutely awesome here was
that while the curses were
successful in their mission this battle
allowed for many of the top students to
really shine as well especially of
course todo and itadori itadori growing
immensely in his use and control of
cursed energy
and toto as you hopefully remember from
his video
has an ideological clash here with
hanami
because total while acknowledging the
fleetiness of things and
the importance of being one with nature
also believes in the ability of humans
to go against this flow and
leave a lasting impact on the worlds
[Music]
the reason hanami is such a wonderful
opponent for toto and his eternal love
for his new besto friendo yuji
is that hanami is the embodiment of
nature itself
which you think might be trivial but
given the importance of nature in the
story what i found is that akutami
actually has given hanami a very unique
position in the story in terms of due to
kaisen's main takeaway messages
are curses born from human sphere of
nature the earth
the sea and the forest and yet to me it
seems like hanami takes a bit of a
special role within the curses as the
embodiment of
living things mahto and jogo want to
destroy human dominance in order to live
out freely in the world as they please
and rule they see themselves as the true
humans and as the superior race
now hanami does share that view but has
a different desire
as a really dark twist on mother nature
that's why i say her see
i promise you it'll make sense as i was
saying as mother nature
hanami seems to not only be born from
humans fear of nature but also of
nature's wrath towards humans
based on all her dialogues to me it
seemed pretty obvious that akutami
writes hanami as a physical
representation
of nature fighting back against all that
we as a species have done to this planet
to all the living things around us but
isn't hanami one of the bad guys
actually describes hanami's presence as
almost spirit-like and i think her
life-based abilities support the idea
that she's kind of a mix between curse
and spirits
spirit yes she did so yes she
clearly has traits of a curse her wish
to destroy humanity her ability to suck
life from the living things around her
and encouraged by mahdal she even starts
embracing her cursed nature a bit more
during the fight with toto and yuji
[Applause]
and yet on the other side of things i'm
not sure about you but to me
it never really feels like hanami was
about to
kill pretty much anyone the very first
word she speaks with fushigoro kama and
inumaki
is calling them children as a mother
would
hanami who must be very ancient indeed
until now clearly has wished to coexist
with humanity and
has come to a breaking point humans are
no longer
bearable to nature however her wish here
is to protect
not to hurt humans per se her name
hanami literally means
cherry blasting viewing in japan an
activity associated with celebrating the
beauty and fleetiness of nature
and getting shit-faced but you get my
points up to this fight she purposefully
has covered up her left arm that
contrary to the pure white of the rest
of her body is dark black and has a much
more curse-like vibe
as it is the source of her ability to
drain nature of energy itself
now to me it clearly looks like she
doesn't like to associate herself with
her
cursed powers
also in this moment right here she
clearly could have seriously injured or
even
killed fushigoro but chose to only aim
for the small little phone in his hand
to prevent the students from contacting
gojol
on top of that hanami's only weakness on
her steel heart body are the two
branches growing where the eyes should
be
these branches symbolizing nature and
its softness
are her only weakness once again showing
the mix between
curse and spirits spirit oh uh
about 11 sir you get what i'm saying
right
i mean jogo doesn't have a weakness like
that he has
a volcano on his head
and when i thought about it in the
context of the story hanami
doesn't even properly qualify as a
villain when you really think about it
without saying that she is justified in
her actions which
i don't think she is she still has a
more peaceful and
noble approach to life than many of the
sorcerers do
[Music]
and when you look at it don't you find
it interesting that the three most
evil guys in the story so far tsukuna
mato
and ghetto are the most human ones
hanami
jogo and cthulhu are basically exploited
for feeling emotions
just as or maybe even stronger than
humans
[Music]
this is the hidden meaning behind
hanami's character
in the end even the curses only serve to
highlight how much we as humans can suck
i believe that akutami's message with
due to kaisen is one
finding out what it means to live a good
life two exploring the depth of human
morality
and three he wants you to watch this
video next